one of our favorite guests from Yahoo
Sports national columnist Dan Wetzel
back here on the show how you doing Dan
I'm great rich how are you I'm doing
fine
okay let's let's get right into it what
happened with Greg Schiano yesterday
best you can tell well I think there's a
couple things one the fan base word got
out he was about to get hired at
Tennessee they had a Memorandum of
Understanding and the fan base reacted
quite negatively they did not want Greg
Schiano to be their head coach I think
most of them didn't want him because
they thought they could get a better
head coach didn't think he's good enough
didn't think he'd fit there didn't think
he'd win all of those things us some I'm
going to guess a soup were upset that he
once worked at Penn State under
defensive coordinator Jerry Sandusky and
at one point in one of the many many
depositions in this case was mentioned
basically as the subject of a rumor that
he had seen something and didn't do
anything and then I think others that
just wanted him to not coach a Tennessee
because they didn't think he was a good
coach jumped on that and everything took
off and so in a matter of a few hours
Tennessee went from about to hire Greg
Schiano to backing off Greg Schiano
because of the molt on social media and
going too far where they were you know
people with signs outside Neyland
Stadium and in probably the most
troubling part to me was a rock they
have at the University of Tennessee that
people know fraternities paint and
different things straight up said Greg
Schiano covered up child child
molestation at Penn State yeah and had
gone from a really really soft
accusation here's double hearsay
accusation - he did it so now let's go
look let's get let's get into that Dan
because you were you were at this trial
you covered it we had you on the show
when it was going down and now that it
is being relitigated in a way what was
let's get into the crux of
what Schiano how his name was mentioned
in that in that trial and why that came
up over the last 24 48 hours so Schiano
was only mentioned in 2015 during a
deposition a civil case involving Penn
State and it's insurer over who
basically had to pay all of Sandusky's
victims and in that in their in that
case there was a deposition of Mike
McQueary is the kind of famously known
as the grad assistant that walked in on
Sandusky and a boy in 2001 and then the
next day told Joe Paterno about it and
nothing was acted on at that time and in
that deposition it was mentioned that
McQueary had talked to a guy named Tom
Bradley who was long 30 something year
assistant under the Joe Paterno and
about Sandusky and and Bradley had told
him that one time Greg Schiano
had said he had seen something it
literally claimed something and was
white as a ghost about it and that was
the extent because it really wasn't
germane to what they were arguing that
was the extent of the questioning there
was no follow-up like what was the
something when was this give us more
details or anything like that that we
got released about 18 months ago when
there was an unsealing of some documents
there's a little bit of attention to it
but that was the extent of the case and
it's again it's a double hearsay
situation Schiano denied it Tom Bradley
denied it and I think what's important
to note is there's there's no other
accusations from anybody else
there's no evidence that this happened
there's no corroboration McQueary was
the star witness for the prosecution for
the attorney general in for criminal
cases Sandusky the ad the president of
the school of the vice president all of
them went away he met with the police
and met with prosecutors for years and
so presumably he told them the same
story also and they never pursued
gianna or tom bradley on these charges
there's no criminal charge against them
there was no Schiano was another
question about it you know and so on no
victim came forward there's no kid that
said yeah I was in a shower once Greg
Schiano walked in there's no civil cases
against him no lawyer took the case and
tried to sue Schiano for this you know
he's rich he's famous all of that the
prosecution that would desperately want
to nail Tom Bradley particularly in Greg
Schiano to a lesser extent in this case
didn't didn't go after it but success
there's just nothing really here or they
would have I don't know what happened I
don't know that and you don't know and
nobody knows except maybe Greg Schiano I
assume Greg Schiano what he did fear of
this story is possibly true but what we
do know is is absolutely no proof and no
other corroboration or evidence that
would ever make you say I'm going from
this kind of accusation to I'm gonna
paint a lock that says Greg Schiano
covered up child molestation at Penn
State is a massive leap bearing a facts
and so I think I wrote a column just
basically explaining that how all the
details of this case is most people had
read hundreds and hundreds of pages or
sat through all this stuff and I think
that's the part that's terrifying is it
just went from this sort of accusation
that nobody really took seriously to he
did it and forget losing the Tennessee
job you know I'm sure Greg Schiano that
will shook at his reputation he's
basically been convicted by some of
these people for being committing one of
the worst crimes you ever could commit
which is just be saying I watched the
guy who left the child and walk away
it's just you know he's almost
unfathomable than anyone would do Dan
Wetzel of Yahoo Sports joining me here
on the Rich Eisen show so Schiano now
goes back to coordinating the defense
for a for an Ohio State team that has
title hopes still in a big 10 tunnel as
well so either either either Schiano
is being is being nailed for something
that he did do okay or an Ohio State has
paid no mind at all or this whole thing
stinks - I haven't Dan right I mean you
is there a is there a gray area in here
no I think the gray area would be you
know saying I don't think we should hire
Greg Schiano because he didn't work for
Jerry Sandusky and he was meant and I
just don't want to have anything to do
with Penn State I don't think that's
necessarily fair to Greg Schiano but I
would get that I think that's a gray
area same she olive did it it's
completely unfair and this Ohio State
was saying that's it's fine at I'm here
I mean wouldn't a state look through it
you know Tennessee had investigated but
there was a again there were four
criminal trials there was a
whistleblower lawsuit there was over 30
civil suits against Penn State there was
an internal investigation led by Louis
Freeh the former FBI director that Penn
State put out the squandered some pages
at no point did Greg Schiano comp in any
of them you know so it's it's like it's
a game and you know there's a reason
hearsay is not admissible I know it's a
court of public opinion but everyone
else's game a telephone like one guy
told another guy he heard something 15
years ago
there's a reason that's not admissible
and it's in and I don't believe Mike
McQueary put it out there to try to
crush you know I don't know what he said
you read this thing in the in the thing
you immediately stop and go what do you
mean something what do you mean about
this what do you say about this there's
none of that
so IANA doesn't have any really way to
defend himself on it so you know to me
you can be suspicious I don't I don't
know but you certainly the same thing
you don't know the other way and there's
really just the guess is if there was
something there to pursue the
prosecutors in Pennsylvania the Attorney
General would have gone after Tom
Bradley and and Greg Schiano with
everything they
had these were big fish they could have
cotton US and they didn't for a reason
and I'd suggest they didn't think there
was any crime there so which is Schiano
the first coach who's been hired a fired
after being hired because of Twitter and
Facebook would you say probably I mean
we've seen coaches walk away from
schools but you just never see a school
walk away from a coach and the idea that
this went down the anger and then just
the amount of pressure put on the ad and
you know I'm not I'm not opposed to fans
voicing their opinion you know and if
you sat there and said I don't again I
don't like them causality good approach
for it so okay I'm really nervous to
having anything to do with ten state I
get that I think that's your gray area
or totally acceptable it's when you just
sit there and start putting out he did
it he did it that's a little terrifying
it's a lot terrifying and you know I
know it's 2017 in facts no matter and we
just do whatever we want to tweet
whatever you want anything goes but you
know so I probably telling him 100 years
old saying maybe we could have a little
bit of everyone could take a moment and
read what you're about to conclude
before painting the lock but I did kind
of like that level of society a little
better this one Dan always love our
chats we'll chat again soon thanks for
calling in appreciate you got to check
it out Dan Wetzel's column on all of
this so Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience